les 180 équipes s'échauffent une
dernière fois dans le départ pour sa
neuvième édition le trophée rassemble
une soixantaine d'entreprises de
l'agglomération
ça fait trois ans qu'on refusait du
monde ont limité à 150 équipes
à force de refuser on a essayé de voir
comment normaux dit fier les épreuves
pour augmenter la jauge de trophées ce
qu'on a fait cette année on se rend
compte que ça permet effectivement de
voir ses collègues sous un autre jour ça
resserre les liens et puis on s'est
rendu compte également qui est une
réelle demande de la part des
entreprises de prendre en compte la
question du sport que ce soit sur les
tours du midi sur les temps juste après
le travail et sur des événements comme
ça
course d'orientation épreuve de radom
relais vtt ou encore sprint
le trophée est avant tout un moment de
cohésion entre salariés ça nous permet
de nous connaître nous mieux nous
connaître d'apprendre aussi à vivre
ensemble à participer aux efforts de
l'entreprise d'une part mais ose
également des efforts qui sont plus
sportifs
et puis aussi affectif a entraîné toutes
les trois on échange à ce qu'on va faire
on a regardé les cartes de l'année
dernière voilà on en parle même demain
la déprime et ça apporte
oui de la cohésion la solidarité ça
permet aussi de rencontrer des personnes
dans l'entreprise qu'on rencontre pas
forcément tous les jours et voilà créer
l'esprit d'équipé boncourt régulièrement
quatre à cinq fois par semaine on a fait
beaucoup de radeaux beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup et du vtt du vtt du vtt la
course d'orientation bas dans le bureau
pour cette édition 2007 un trio masculin
de la ceppm basée à montigny le
bretonneux qui l'emportent pour la
deuxième année consécutive
ça fait peur